[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Cheryl is
in Medford Oregon hi Cheryl welcome to
the Ramsey Show
thank you Dave and Rachel for taking my
call this is a first time caller and I'm
a little
um
um I'm happy to be here well we're
honored to have you glad you're here
Cheryl
big breath so um I have a question
um
I'm in my late 60s and I'm married
happily to my husband we have five adult
children I've been listening for about a
year
and um what's changed and my situation
is my mom passed away about five minutes
ago I'm sorry
and um thank you um it's been uh she was
sick for a while so you know it still
was hard but the situation is she left
we grew up on a piece of property there
in she's been there since about 1958
and we all grew up there and now this
property is in a trust and we're all
trying to figure out how to divide it
amongst us
and it's just been um really volatile
not that I
um haven't contributed to it because I
I'm you know a woman but um I just want
to do an honor the Lord and just
you know honor my sister and my brother
but it's difficult because they've all
put a lot of money into the ranch
and my mother has it in the estate that
she wants it divided amongst us and
we've kind of been an outsider because
we branched in other places
and now we're here now and we're just
trying to figure out our role what are
the what is the trust asking people to
do and what is it they don't want to do
um the trust has asked that we divided
equally amongst ourselves how is that
fair if they put money into it and you
didn't
um
let's see how do I go about that
um they they invested it in areas that
benefited them in in kind of a an area
that they wanted to
um how did it benefit them they didn't
own it
did they make money off of that
yes one was in uh hemp
um trying to grow him for a couple years
and building a building that um utilized
that resource and then another was yeah
but that building now has a value
regardless of whether hemp's in it or
not correct fifty thousand yeah and that
that building if they built that
building with their money your mom
didn't that should be their money right
correct if I was them that's how I would
see it
okay
which is let me tell you the whole idea
that they would build a building on
someone else's property without having
everything lined out in the Trust In
detail was pretty stupid
because it sets up a big argument
your mother and
um your brothers and sisters should have
their butts kicked for not doing this
properly because it leaves you in a
lurch
so they what is it they're wanting to do
the brothers and sisters my sister has
moved a lot of property uh
a property some of them legitimate and
some of them not and then she wanted
um 150 000 for providing care for my
mother
but the trust doesn't allocate that
no and then her she lived on the
property and her children did 50 of her
children did at the same time for the
last five years with no rent
correct okay
and so
um
well uh so I guess the negotiating is
that
um I assume you guys have an estate is
there who's the trustee
my brother oh Jesus
okay the youngest and so he's really
caught in this bless his heart yeah he
is yeah okay so his job
unless you guys come to a mutual
conclusion otherwise
he doesn't have a choice
he legally has to follow the terms of
the trust
whether he wants to or not
he is only out is that everyone agree to
something different and go along with it
but otherwise he's going to divvy this
up straight up he has to
because otherwise he's liable for suit
he is a fiduciary trust responsibility
as the trustee to execute the terms of
the trust if he doesn't any one of you
that are the beneficiaries would have
have cause against him so Cheryl the
fact that you know that there's other
you know they've put money into it how
are you feeling are you are you on one
side saying yeah you got to divide it up
a third a third a third it's what it
says or are you like I want to be fair
in this and do the right thing I just
don't know what it is where are you at
in all of it
well it's kind of complicated because
um
all the assets are on one part of the
property it's it's worth 2.2 but it's
hard uh some of it's exclusive farming
and so you can't really do anything with
it and not necessarily can build on it
and that's the part that we've been
interested in but then when we research
it it's going to be pretty expensive to
try to you know put things in we have to
do to live there and we live about an
hour away why don't you just sell it
and that's that's a possibility too and
just sell your part oh
oh we've we've just wanted to farm you
know it's kind of our way to to try to
well we have cattle we don't have a
place for them we've had we have a
couple that at the ranch right now but
we have um so you're thinking about
moving on the property
well we've been thinking about it but
it's been next door to all these people
that you disagree with well that sounds
joyful that's what I'm concerned about
yeah I guess so
that doesn't sound fun at all
like next door to my brother who's still
mad about something that happened 15
years ago
oh my God uh
uh I would have to have real good solid
loving harmonious relationships before
I'd want to live next door to them and I
don't know if this story you're telling
me ends there
so you need to consider that part of it
but here's the here's the here's your
bottom line on the whole thing
let's pretend that you wanted to allow
your
hemp brother and your sister
tenant
to get a little more than you got
because they put buildings on it in my
mind uh the care that she provided for
your mom is offset by the fact she got
free rent so that's absolute bull I'm
dropping that one if I'm you but
um she gets nothing uh she already got
it it's called free rent and so then
whoever brought buildings on will take
the value of those buildings out of the
equation
and then split what's left three ways
then they get their buildings back and
so that because you should not benefit I
don't think ethically from them putting
a building on the property because you
didn't put money in it it's their money
again the whole thing was dum dum dum
dum dum
that you all let that the family did
this doing this stuff is how people end
up not speaking to each other
generationally you end up with the
Hatfields and The McCoys and so
you know you're just you know it's just
dumb but anyway so that's water under
the bridge but let's say that you said
all right we're gonna take the buildings
off now we run an appraisal then you get
your buildings back
on so you you know you got you got your
buildings back and then I get my third
of what's left I would agree to doing
that and no 150 000 that is exchange for
the free rent if you all agree to that
then little brother the trustee can go
along with that otherwise he has to
execute the trust he does not have a
choice all right guys
um last call uh about the estate that's
messed up in the late 60s brothers and
sisters that are left fighting because
their parents and them did business very
poorly uh what is the takeaway number
one takeaway
if you're 18 years old or older you need
a will
period
now let's understand what a will is
if I if I have a will if I uh will it
for if it is my will for Rachel to be on
the show she's on the show okay as a
guest or as a host co-host right okay if
I have a if if it is my will to wear a
green jacket today I will get it out of
the closet that's that's what you want
to have happen is your will
okay that's what I'm having a will means
this is what you will it's what you want
to have happen
in your last will and testament it's the
last thing you want to have happen and
you are testifying to that fact
that's all that means so this is what I
want to have happen when I do a will
and the executor of the will the word
executor is one who executes
they execute what I wanted to have
happen
they don't have a choice same is true of
a trustee on a trust
the executor can't change the will
it's not their job
and even if they don't like it even if
they think it's not fair they can't just
change it the trustee can't change the
terms of the trust it's not their job
their job is to execute those the what
that person intended to have happen what
they wanted what they willed to have
happen and they testified to that fact
okay so keeping your will up to date is
huge
it should be done in the state according
to the laws of the state in which you
reside so if you change States get a new
will
any other major thing that happens
divorce get a new will
death of a
someone that's in the will get a new
will
update your freaking will
because it's incomplete it's wrong you
can't execute it if you live in Idaho
and you did a will in Tennessee
okay it doesn't it's not federal law
it's state law
probate law is state law so yeah it's
done according to the laws of the state
you reside in when you die
and so if your will is done something or
asked for something to be done that the
laws of that state you're residing in
don't allow and you haven't updated it
you're screwed up the whole thing
this is called grown-up paperwork
grown-ups do a will
I might die you're gonna die
it does not increase your probability of
death when you do a will you're going to
die is a hundred percent death rate in
the human race okay plus or minus Elijah
and Jesus okay the rest of us are gonna
die okay so that's it you're gonna get a
will go to mama bear legal forms if you
have a basic uh life and you don't have
a lot of complication and get an
inexpensive will online it's a great
will but it's state specific Mama Bear
legal forms we've endorsed them for
years you've got a complicated situation
get an attorney get an estate planning
attorney
I have spent an amazing amount of money
on estate planning to keep the
government's freaking hands off of it
and then once a year we have a little
meeting with all the Ramses and all the
leaders at Ramsey and we tell everybody
and it's labeled if Dave dies this year
that's the name of the meeting if Dave
dies this year it's we call it the Monty
Python meeting I'm feeling much better
it's just a flesh wound but yeah uh oh
my God and we shouldn't talk about my
death for an hour and a half
what has changed since last year in the
operation of Ramsey and the operation of
this piece of real estate going scuba
diving what are all the ways I do all
the stuff I do all the stuff so I'm not
gonna quit doing all the stuff that's
not the point because I'm gonna die it's
part of the program so I'm I'm good with
that because Heaven's on the other side
of it I'm perfectly good with that so
anyway get a freaking will and when
you're gonna do stuff with a family
piece of ground like that family had and
you're gonna I'm gonna move in with my
mind I'm Gonna Take Care of Mama oh by
the way I'm charging all y'all 150k well
kiss my butt I don't think so
we can stop that on the front end we
don't have to have an issue here you're
going to move in take care of Mom so are
you expecting to be paid uh we're gonna
write all this down
uh or we think you should be paid
because I'm happy you're there to take
care of Mom okay I'm more than happy
with that and so if you get more of the
estate because you took I'm happy with
that but we should do all of this in
writing as a part of the program and
then not leave it behind confused and so
if you're doing something in your will
like I'm not going to leave Jim Bob any
money because Jim Bob does heroin and
he'll go get heroin and kill himself so
Jim Bob you're out of the will go ahead
and tell Jim Bob while you're alive
because he's going to be pissed and you
might as well have the pleasure of him
being pissed while you're alive
heroin I don't know you Stir It Up Stir
It Up maybe it'll clean him up but I
mean go ahead you know this this stuff
of we're going to go into the paneled
Office of the lawyer and the weird uh
plastic surgery induced stepmother and
the uh inbred child and all this other
stuff in there like some movie or and
we're going to have a reading of the
will that only happens in a movie
okay a bad movie and we've all seen the
movie all right several of them so in
real life real people go ahead and
communicate with their family they say
brother is putting a fifty thousand
dollar hemp building on the property
God help us and so brother is going to
get
not gonna that fifty thousand dollar
building is not going to be included in
the value that is split three ways
because it's his freaking money and
we're gonna write that into the trust
before brother because he apparently
smoke in the hemp put the building on
there without freaking dictating that he
was going to get his own money back okay
so people listening though right now God
need to get a will yes but what do you
say to people because I get this
question a lot that my parents they
don't want to talk about it they don't
want to do a will whenever we try to
bring up the conversation they shut it
down well then don't put a building on
their property okay I know but but
what's your advice what would you say to
someone though that's like how do I help
my parents see that they need a will so
that we're not in this situation Mom and
Dad we love you so much we would love to
see that your legacy has carried out the
way you want it to be carried out
when it's all in your head nobody knows
what the flip you want to have happen so
maybe you ought to write it down it's
called a will
it's what grown-ups do okay and by the
way by the way the government's going to
end up with a bunch of this too if you
don't if you're going to screw around
and do this right some of these Estates
that's a two million dollar estate there
that one is not going to be subject to
federal estate tax now but it would have
been under Obama
okay and so uh Trump's estate uh limits
are still in place right now because
Biden hadn't gotten around to screwing
that up but uh but he will eventually
once he wakes up from well anyway the um
all right so I mean seriously people
write it down and then have a review
with your family here's what we want to
have happen I'll give you another
example okay the this is public
knowledge so I'm not telling some big
Tale the Ramsay kids now own the vast
majority of this company I own a
minority position but I own the only
voting stock so I'm still in control
okay we transferred that out of our
names Sharon will get none of this
company if I die before Sharon does
it'll go straight to the kids as part of
our estate plan
by the way Sharon knows that Sharon
doesn't want anything to do with this
place the kids are going to run it
that's what she does she just wants
money that's all she wants and so we got
that we got Miss Sharon set up because
we the whole estate plan is also
presupposing I'm going to die first
which means she has a plan so
golly so anyway that's an example though
okay that's a weird thing it didn't go
to my wife and then to my kids it went
straight to my kids
and uh and she's one of the owners prior
to that yeah two so but you talk about
this crap and you put it down in writing
it's called a will it's called a trust
that's updated so people do your Will
and tell everybody
about it that is in it or not in it so
that they don't have to fight about it
later